Hello friends,
huh?
Have you already seen the 2nd communication?
Well,
Koldo
Garcia the right hand man not only of Avalos,
but also of Pedro,
because the one who guarded
the endorsements
of the primaries of Pedro's socialist party
It was still Koldo and it is in the documents.
But well, is this
the 2nd of shoddy mercenaries
of this country in Spain?
Well, no, no,
are not even able to say it
after almost 2 years and 2nd year of research,
getting the right hand to
and 1 of the front men of Minister Ãvalos eh
these statements,
by the way,
for which I have 2 pending lawsuits
against Mr.
Avalos and Mr.
Koldo,
for speaking your mind
1 police investigation and for which
They have been arrested eh?
Em,
after seeing this and seeing our successes.
eh judicial,
also against Mr.
Oscar Ponte,
current Minister of Infrastructure.
How curious that the most presumably golfers
always put them in infrastructures.
It will have something to do with having the budget,
1 of the budgets
largest in the Spanish government
and that is where it is very,
very easy to collect commissions,
because when you do large public works
is very easy
talk to the construction companies so that you can win
3 5 or 10 million euros.
Anyway,
what questions do I ask,
right?
After seeing all this judicial harassment,
and what I will publish in the next few days,
what is 1 interview
I think VA to write the foot
the foot of 1 small
but important page in the history of our country.
Have I decided that it is impossible to continue
with this task of removing the dirty laundry
to the worst scale
political and media in Spain and also in the judiciary.
eh?
Going so to speak naked,
that is,
from civil society,
it is impossible.
That's why I wanted to tell you that I have decided to
to run in the next elections
European elections on Sunday,
June 9,
if I am not mistaken,
so that the Spanish People
consider whether we are given the attribute of trust
when it comes to having 1 em,
because it is quite important in institutional institutions
have 1
and have 1 mirror that makes
eh we cannot be every week in 1 trial
and that regardless of whether we win or not,
they are not always condemned for costs.
But every time we investigate 1 corrupt minister,
each time we research their environment,
every time we research
to the whole scheme of businessmen around them,
they impute us,
they slander us,
we are sued
with thes of the 2nd communication system
that do not give us an echo
and therefore we have 1 serious problem to defend ourselves.
That is why I have decided to
that from today I will join the team,
we are going to tour Spain
to prepare us for Cara to the signature collection
and we are going to run in the next elections
European elections.
That the Spanish people decide to
if we can count on the
institutional that Europe gives us,
from where they depart unconditionally
Much of our problems as well,
that the Pac,
agriculture,
in the end.
So guys,
let's talk about it.
And by the way,
1 short question to show you once again what they are,
what the Mafia is in the 2nd of communication
in the country,
El Mundo, ABC,
reason,
the everyday eh,
the avant-garde,
objective populi voice.
In all 2o
the theme of Avalos and his right hand and close friend
eh,
president of Cruz Zamora,
is on the cover of everything but 1,
guess what?
2o is not on the cover
effectively
in Don Eduardo Inda's 2nd okay diario.
Does it have anything to do with Eduardo Inda
and Ãvalos to close advertising agreements
of the Ministry of Infrastructure?
It has something to do with
to sit and eat once a month
in Avalos' own house,
where I was criminalized by both of them for
that alleged image
in the courtyard of the minister's house.
It is now understood
why I have put so much effort into it
to investigate Minister Avalos,
your son Victor
and to this whole tangle
which has ended with 1
excellent work of the Civil Guard?
Well,
let's go together,
gentlemen,
let's raise Spain.